[Aplausos]
les voy a contar una historia real que
empezó como una broma
pero que se fue de las manos sin llegó
mucho más lejos de lo que teníamos
pensado
en 2008 un compañero de la carrera
fernando cervera y yo creamos una página
web
en esa página web decíamos que existía
una nueva terapia alternativa que era
capaz de curar enfermedades utilizando
imanes
mezclados con caca
la fe con magnetoterapia
además decíamos que cuanto menos caca
hubiese más poderoso sería el
medicamento si no había casi nada mejor
además para consumir para
facilidad del consumidor final vendían
muchos formatos distintos por ejemplo en
comprimidos en jarabes en pomadas para
la cara en inhaladores también
y pusimos como pequeñas pistas a lo
largo de toda la página web que hacían
muy sencillo darse cuenta de que eso era
todo mentira por ejemplo dijimos que los
prestigiosos médicos que habían
inventado esta terapia se llamaban
leslie lóriz y julián a lo mejor les
suena los nombres porque no los
inventamos mezclando los apellidos de
estos dos actores
también poníamos fotos falsas podíamos
imágenes de ambientadores que claramente
ponían ambientador de lavanda
ambientador de pino y decíamos que eso
en verdad eran pulverizadores de imanes
con caca
favorecían la sanación de las
enfermedades respiratorias era bastante
poco creíble
pues fue una bola de nieve
al poco tiempo plataformas de venta
online ofrecían nuestros productos
nos entrevistamos con otros terapeutas
alternativos y no solamente no se daban
cuenta de que era un invento sino que
nos ofrecían colaborar con ellos y dar
cursos en sus instalaciones
nos escribió un extra asesor
presidencial de mexico y nos pidió que
el doctor yu nielsen escribiese el
prólogo para su próximo libro de
terapias alternativas
también escribimos a todos los miembros
del congreso de diputados les
preguntamos cuál era su opinión sobre
las terapias alternativas como el con
magnetoterapia
ahí no tuvimos tanto éxito porque
solamente recibimos una respuesta de una
portavoz de sanidad que nos dijo que ese
tipo de terapias
deberían promocionarse y estar cubiertas
por la seguridad social
también tuvimos otra gran oportunidad
que fue la de participar en la feria
esotérica y de terapias alternativas de
atocha en la estación de trenes en
madrid el evento más grande de este tipo
ahí podíamos y queríamos poner un stand
donde vender nuestros productos hecho
con caca
no teníamos tales productos y además
había que pagar y la otra opción era dar
una conferencia explicando las bondades
de la caja que además pero claro frente
a una audiencia alguien se iba a dar
cuenta
o no
dimos una conferencia donde nos
inventamos un montón de datos como que
los aborígenes argentinos se frotaban
kaká para curar su enfermedad es todo
inventado
y no solamente nadie se dio cuenta de
que eso era mentira sino que nos
empezaron a volver a participar
al año siguiente
toda esta experiencia nos hizo poner en
duda todas las terapias alternativas y a
los terapeutas evidentemente
a nosotros nunca nadie nos freno el
carro
nadie se extrañó de que dos veinteañeros
fuesen la máxima exponencial de una
nueva terapia que curaba con kaká en la
península ibérica
y nadie nos preguntó
donde habíamos aprendido a curar
enfermedades
oa diagnosticar las
existen muchísimas terapias alternativas
se ofrecen en farmacias en clínicas en
ferias
en universidades
yo les pregunto a esos terapeutas
alternativos
donde aprendieron a curar a diagnosticar
alguien les pregunto si eso que hacen
tiene alguna evidencia de funcionamiento
uno de los argumentos que van a escuchar
más habitualmente es que esto no hace
daño a nadie
él es mario
mari o en la época de la foto
estudiadas físicas en la universidad de
valencia mi universidad en el campus de
burjassot
a mario le diagnosticaron cáncer
un terapeuta alternativo le ofreció un
tratamiento que no tenía los efectos
secundarios de la quimioterapia
mari abandonó su tratamiento
convencional de medicina
y al poco tiempo murió
todos conocemos a algún pariente algún
amigo que utiliza terapias alternativas
a lo mejor esa persona iba caminando por
atocha el día que nosotros vendíamos
otros productos
somos muy exigentes
a la hora de hacer cumplir los horarios
del transporte público
la cantidad de aire que tiene la bolsa
de patatas
la fecha en la que se van a poner los
adornos de navidad este año
yo creo que deberíamos ser igual de
exigentes
a la hora de hacer cumplir las leyes que
deberían proteger aquello que más
valoramos
nuestra salud
porque la permisividad que hay frente
las terapias alternativas algunas
personas ya les ha costado la vida
e